translation begins in a specific
sequence known as shine-dalgarno
sequence after initiation the ribosome
moves along the RNA and as it moves
along the amino acids are piled up and
forming a peptide this is how the
protein translation takes place inside a
prokaryote and also eukaryote cells now
the building block of this peptide are
the amino acids have you ever wondered
what are the molecules which can bring
these amino acids to ribosome such that
it can really Nick the whole necklace
and these molecules are charged tRNA
which are loaded with a new amino acid
and have a anticodon loop which is just
complementary to the RNA sequence or the
complementary to the codons in this
video we are going to look at how this
loading of amino acid onto the tRNA
takes place this process is otherwise
known as aminoacylation of tRNA so if
you haven't yet subscribe the channel
why are you waiting for
in the subscribe button and watch this
video till the end so the key ingredient
for this aminoacylation reaction is that
tRNA synthetase this is the key enzyme
which is involved in this process let's
talk about the structure of this enzyme
in a bit more details this enzyme has an
amino acid binding groove where the
amino acids are actually bound and are
to be loaded on the tRNA then it has an
ATP binding motif which binds to ATP
because this process of aminoacylation
is ATP dependent and there is a tRNA
binding motif which binds to the
anticodon loop of the trna all these
domain ensures the amino acid T RNA and
ATP are in proximity such that the
optimal reaction can
go on now let's talk about the
aminoacylation process in bit more
details before that you should always
remember that mg 2 plus ions are really
important in this process of
aminoacylation so the first step is the
aminoacylation in this aminoacylation
process is addition of the amino acid
with the ATP which is already bound to
the ATP binding motif so the amino acids
firms born with the phosphate group of
the ATP and stay there in the active
site the next step the tRNA comes in at
the end of the tRNA in the 3 prime CCA
motive
there are hydroxyl groups these hydroxyl
groups mount electro new nucleophilic
attack into the carboxyl group of the
amino acids and as a result there is a
rearrangement and the aminoacylation
reaction takes place now many of the
cases the hydroxyl group is not the 2
prime hydroxyl group rather than its a 3
prime hydroxyl group in that case the
tRNA synthesis synthetase is known as
type 2 while the normal case where there
is 2 prime hydroxyl group as a nuclear
fill the trna synthetase is known as
type 1 trna synthetase after that beat
any type of our amino ethyle same that
is the tRNA would be charged and can be
loaded to the ribosome and after that a
chain of amino acids
would form a polypeptide and in this
video we just looked at the process of
aminoacylation in with more details so I
hope you enjoyed this video if you liked
this video give it a thumbs up don't
forget to Like share and subscribe thank
you